difícil para mim quem não é da área de
produto porque as pessoas perguntam
porque que precisa existir uma área de
produto E por que que precisa tanta
gente na área de produto como que fazem
como se alimentam convivem
[Música]
Olá hoje nós estamos começando mais um
episódio do mesa de produto e o tema de
hoje é sobre escalar a área de produto
afinal se não tem um único jeito só de
fazer produto também não tem um único
jeito de escalar a área de produto e é
por isso que ele te trouxe hoje Fernanda
faria cipiou do Zé delivery Camila Lopes
pra dar um tiro de nubank E mais uma vez
esse homem Rafael farinazzi eu sou
Marcelo Almeida e eu sou um rosto desse
Episódio Eu espero que você deixa um
like no YouTube se você está assistindo
e principalmente para ajudar os outros
que o time de marketing você clica em
assinar esse canal porque vai vir muito
conteúdo Boa noite Isso demonstra para
gente que tem pessoas gostando do nosso
conteúdo e para abrir o episódio vou
jogar uma pergunta a gente pode começar
aqui nessa ordem Fernanda e depois
Camila e Farina também se quiser
contribuir que é qual o maior desafio de
vocês hoje para escalar área de produto
as pessoas que não são da área de
produto
conte mais
Coitada dessas pessoas elas podem ouvir
esse episódio você pode usar esse
episódio para mandar o recado que você
quer mandar
acho que cria uma boa discussão aqui na
verdade o mais difícil para mim quem não
é da área de produto porque as pessoas
perguntam porque que precisa existir uma
área de produto E por que você é tanta
gente na área de produto como que fazem
como se alimentam convivem então eu
diria que o mais difícil que a gente tem
como é uma não contexto que ainda é novo
embora a gente já esteja nele algum
tempo mas para grande maioria para o
mestre minha e da população é um tema
novo então quando você vai para alguns
lugares Tá bom mas o que que o PM faz
ele move Cardino gira é da Teia cara tem
conserta impressora
ele vai anotar o que eu preciso
eu acho que tem um desafio muito grande
atual para escalar área de produto em
qualquer empresa mais tradicional que é
a versão a risco assim então acho que
muito de você escalar uma área de
produto tem a ver também como você
escalar todo mais este produto que vem
junto né e dessa tomada de decisão
focada em proposta de valor em muitas
vezes você investir em coisas que você
não tem tanta certeza do resultado e
fazer apostas né e o que eu vejo na
maioria das grandes empresas é uma
versão muito grande a risco uma
necessidade Às vezes você tem um
processo de decisão muito formal para
você conseguir priorizar as coisas e é
isso machuca muito essa cultura e tipos
de decisão e a velocidade com que as
coisas são feitas
de alinhamento também porque enfim cada
vez mais difícil você garantir que as
pessoas estão indo
para onde elas deveriam tá indo ou pelo
menos tão alinhadas Às vezes você
descobre que tem dois squares fazendo a
mesma coisa e Eles simplesmente
decidiram não se conversar coisas do
tipo então começando pelo seu ponto aí
que você falou do desafio serem as
pessoas por elas não entenderem muito
bem o que a pessoa de produto faz como
que você tá tentando lidar com isso e
não sei se a primeira vez você tá
lidando com isso ou seja você já teve
que lidar outras vezes e como como
resolver esse problema é a segunda vez
de alguma forma tô lidando com isso mas
quando a gente pensa também é parte do
nosso trabalho de alguma forma explicar
o que a gente está fazendo né E por que
que a gente existe então e você tem
forma de explicar né porque eu acho da
comunicação você nunca vai achar um
jeito único de comunicar então de
repente com farinado eu posso ser mais
teórica com Marcel Putz eu vou ter que
explicar na prática vou ter que trazer o
Marcelo para fazer um exercício para
entender como funciona a mentalidade o
que que faz então ou vou pegar o exemplo
de benchmark para pegar De outra empresa
e falou olha só que um exemplo as
pessoas elas recebem informações de
múltiplas formas então uma das coisas
que eu vejo é como que a gente aprende a
falar vários idiomas no final das contas
porque esses idiomas vão conectar com as
pessoas que estão ao redor e entender
o porquê Porque é importante Aonde tá o
valor que o valor além daquele que a
pessoa tinha como perspectiva Inicial
você área de produto pode entregar
também que muitas vezes assim as pessoas
veem era de produto é para arrumar o
backlog para a gente ter visibilidade do
que tá acontecendo
você foi mais bruto falei só arrumar o
teclado não é assim eu acabei de começar
nem beber ainda
e eu tenho um outro lado que no final
das contas a gente consegue agregar o
mundo de informações tem entrevista com
usuário tem sites que você vai ter em
cima de dados tem teste que você pode
fazer então como é que você divide Na
verdade o Racional com as pessoas de
produto né e não simplesmente falar olha
eu fiz um Discovery tá aqui eu sou o
Grande Mestre eu olhei a bola aqui que o
que eu tenho que fazer então o que eu
gosto de pensar é cara divide o racional
porque o racional faz sentido porque tem
lógica e na hora que você dividir as
pessoas entendem Ah tá então é isso
bacana E aí deixa eu ajudar em nome que
elas quiserem que aí todo mundo fica
feliz
de todas as outras assim
financeira é mais difícil marketing é
mais difícil talvez por uma distância
maior da nossa Cultura
Cara eu não sei assim
financeiro Talvez seja mais difícil Se
você não souber falar o idioma do
financeiro Então se você não consegue
traduzir o que você tá querendo dizer
para resultado no pneu onde você impacta
que linha do Pinel aqui ó essa esse
Squad e impacta nessas linhas esse outro
nessas linhas se você não fala o idioma
dele aí vai ficar difícil mas é isso
você no final tem que falar o idioma de
todas as outras áreas pegando esse
gancho tem muita questão de valor de
produto né Parece que gestão de produto
resolve dores diferentes dos clientes
internos da empresa né então marketing
vai ter uma série de dores que
Possivelmente vai ser sei lá mas
relacionado a visibilidade a tipo
previsibilidade enquanto você vai ter
outros times que você vai estar falando
O problema é que eu resolver aqui é
priorização problema que eu resolver
aqui com uma boa gestão de produto é
tomar decisões melhores valor né Então
dependendo quem é o stakeholder que você
tá falando ali o problema que a gestão
de produto resolve é totalmente
diferente às vezes né então é adaptar
essa linguagem
concordo 100% falando em problema quero
aproveitar esse momento para falar com
os solos é delivery que a empresa que a
Fernanda faria trabalho pode reparar
estamos aqui com cervejas do grupo e
temos interesse no Patrocínio um caso
pessoal
você pode negociar eu avisei a Feia que
eu ia fazer esse Jabá quero deixar claro
se quiser patrocinar a gente pode
sincera a gente faz aí um Fit seu pode
do Zé delivery Também
nada nessa vida vem de graça Ah tudo bem
a gente faz uma pergunta uma negociação
amigável a gente não pode pedir
Patrocínio não sei se pode pedir
Patrocínio lá também não
Juro Zero né
como é que é para ti essa parte da
comunicação ali com os setores queria
ouvir um pouco também da tua experiência
e não só acho que também somar se tem
formatos que você acha que funcionam
mais de maneira mais eficiente ou menos
eficiente também Ah isso é uma conversa
engraçada assim eu tô num contexto agora
de trabalhar com muito mais próximo do
engenharia assim né E tem Eu já percebi
Nesse contexto novo de trabalho remoto
parece que criou-se culturas diferentes
de trabalho nesse mundo remoto assim né
então o time que eu tava antes
funcionava muito melhor a reunião
apresentação e você tipo sentar com a
pessoa e conversar com ela e mostrar o
valor o time que eu tô agora cara é um
documento escrito assim é você escrever
num documento isso é mega pragmático
assim sabe pensamento de engenheiro tipo
analíticos sabe mostra o Framework
mostra o benefício para você resolvidos
formato de documento é o formato que
eles absorvem melhor assim então isso é
muito interessante assim tipo parece que
essas pequenas culturas que se criou de
trabalho dentro dos times mesmo na mesma
empresa assim variam muito até pelo pela
composição dos times né Você tem um time
que é mais engenharia o time que é mais
marketing e é isso muda muito essa
cultura de forma de conversar assim mas
porque seu time são muito mais técnicos
É por isso é hoje em dia eu tô num time
que é praticamente só engenharia então
tô num time que acho que 90% da Business
é de Engenheiros então também nesse
momento de trazer a cultura de produto
mais para dentro
e nesse momento já vi que esse formato
de documentação e esse formato de pouco
do café falou de trazer Putz eu vou te
mostrar a proposta e te mostrar os
benefícios que eu vou atingir com essa
proposta que eu tô trazendo assim você
tem que trazer muito
exemplos e trazer muito coisas
documentadas e Claras e você tipo bater
um papo e tentar escutar tipo meio que
individualmente cada pessoa e tentar
ir no individual parece que é muito
menos influente do que se você conseguir
chegar no framer uma coisa mais
estruturada que é uma linguagem comum
para todo mundo assim enquanto que a
gente fez anteriores A gente já era o
contrário você tem que ir influenciando
stakeholder Chaves e conversando com
essas pessoas e ganhando sponsorship
daquela cultura óbvio que você ter
exponsor né pessoas que estão te
ajudando nessa luta é muito importante
sempre mas eu sinto que tem uma
diferença assim de qualquer forma com
que você tá correndo atrás dessa desse
apoio como é que você tá distribuindo
isso eu gostei que assim a gente acabou
indo mais para cultura de produto e Como
escalar a cultura de produtos acho que
super vale a gente saber em poucos em um
tweet o que que é cultura de produto
para cada uma de vocês porque é uma
pergunta legal a gente costuma fazer em
outros lugares também aqui em outros
episódio que a gente fez isso o que que
você como é que você definiria a cultura
de produto assim de maneira é porque
você falou assim tô levando a cultura de
produtos para saber u que é mais
dinheiro e acho que é o mesmo caso que a
Fê falou ali né que por favor é claro
fica à vontade é o mesmo caso ali como é
que você fala com as pessoas que não são
de produto um pouco mais sobre a cultura
de produto então enfim falei demais
quero ouvir de vocês o que que em um
Twitch O que que a cultura de produto eu
vou tentar ser resumida talvez não seja
daí vocês cortam
eu acho que a cultura de produtos tem
muito a ver com você começar do valor
gerado e das Dores que você quer
resolver do bícerosol do cliente assim
então você começar do Macro para depois
você ir para o micro então a forma que
eu vejo
pessoas de produto é por onde você
começa o processo de tomada de decisão
assim você não vai começar tipo olhando
para o monte de request previsão do
tempo você vai olhar tipo cara não vou
entender qualquer estratégia do meu
negócio quais são eu não tô sem nada
Resumindo né
É difícil para caramba
mas eu acho que é isso assim acho que é
muito de começar do Macro antes de ir
para o micro Então você começa com uma
visão mais holística de todas as
oportunidades e problemas que você tem
que resolver e trazer essa visão que
conecte Dores dos clientes com
valor para o negócio né então você
começar disso como
o start de qualquer processo de
priorização defesa organização enfim
como a gente faz um Twitter a gente pega
um pedaço da tread
[Risadas]
pegar um pedaço da tread para mim
cultura de produto é você
resolver ter a possibilidade de resolver
o mesmo problema de várias formas então
uma vez que você entende com mais
profundidade de problema você sabe onde
ele tá conectado Vamos criar ele
formatos para resolver aquela mesma dor
na minha cabeça sempre brinco com time
tem três formas pessoas processos e
produto
então às vezes você vai resolver só com
pessoas vê se vai resolver mudando os
processos você resolver com o produto às
vezes os três mas é isso é o mindset de
cara tem um n forma de resolver aquela
mesma dor é um mais sete de
experimentação testar uma série de
hipóteses e só que tudo que vocês estão
falando seja cultura de produto ou seja
tudo isso envolve alinhamento que foi um
dos problemas que a gente falou e
envolve tanto manage up quanto menos
Gente vou usar esse tema
para os seus pais e onde vocês têm
encontrado os maiores desafios hoje é no
UP é no site é normal na carreira de
vocês aonde normalmente teve esses
maiores desafios
porque a gente fala muito de uma energia
e muitas vezes nem é esse tanto problema
dependendo da situação eu já tive em
contextos que foi bem diferente acho que
já vi muito do minha energia up que é
tipo você tá Numa célula de inovação
digital está uma célula de estamos
estamos introduzindo cultura de produto
do boro-up né quando você está fazendo
isso de cima para baixo aí você pula vai
ser no
na gestão superior que você tem que meio
que provar para eles a forma diferente
de pensar que é um meio tipo você vai
falhar mais mas você também vai entregar
mais rápido e às vezes até uma muitas
vezes esse parte de convence muitas
vezes até Entra muito em questões muito
mais de ajuda do que de produto em si né
Às vezes você tá falando muito mais de
questões até um pouco de execução e tipo
parar de ter coisa de Budget para
projeto e você falar de tipo cara vou
ter um backlog com peão sabe vou ter um
problema para resolver vou ter um
resultado para atingir mas não vou ter
um projeto tipo que eu vou te dizer o
prazo nem o orçamento que eu vou para
entregar esse projeto e quando está
falando managedown aí eu vejo que o
desafio às vezes é
Eu sinto que depende um pouco da cultura
da empresa tipo eu sinto por exemplo
nubank então uma cultura super
colaborativa então foi Apesar de eu
estar um pouco e vem desse desafio um
pouco agora eu sinto que eu tenho
abertura para falar mas já teve Desafios
que eu não tinha tanto o que eu sinto é
que o maior a maior barreira para você
chegar para o time falar Putz A gente
tem que mudar um pouco framer para ser
mais para produto eu sinto que a maior
barreira é as pessoas saírem do escopo
atual delas assim do quadradinho atual
delas então às vezes elas têm uma forma
que ela já aprenderam de fazer algo um
escopo já definido um problema já
definido e ela ficou muito presas nisso
Muitas vezes os problemas que produto
resolve não problema daquela pessoa
individualmente né vai resolver um
problema que é mais organização que é
mais da priorização que é mais maximizar
o valor gerado e não uma dor daquela
pessoa individualmente então acho que às
vezes você tem uma resistência a mudança
muito grande porque para a pessoa é tipo
cara sei lá eu tô aqui escrevendo um
código eu vou continuar aqui escrevendo
um código de qualquer entendeu então
que que eu tava falando tudo isso
se o maior Qual dos maiores desafios
pela experiência de vocês Qual o maior
desafio mas dá uma energia de sites
Então acho que no mérito a gente tem
esse desafios assim de
influenciar as pessoas de forma
efetiva e colaborativa e acho que tem
muita inércia e aí eu acho que a inércia
pesa um pouco mais assim no meio de Down
porque entra muito no com uma pessoa faz
o trabalho dela né E às vezes pode até
falar pô pode entrar em micro
gerenciamento pode entrar tem uma série
de temas ali que você tem que ter muita
sutileza na forma com que você traz isso
para o time
exato então eu sinto que às vezes fazer
o
de baixo para cima ele é mais fácil no
sentido de tipo eu sinto que você
consegue cavar caminho mais fácil mas
você tem que ter muito mais sutileza e
às vezes você tem que ter muito mais
tempo para falar com as pessoas
individualmente e Cuidar dessa dessa
coisa da
esse aqui esse nome disso não essa
unidade mental segurança psicológica e
cuidar da segurança do
pré-requisito
e cuidar muito dessa segurança
psicológica das pessoas individualmente
para você não perder a cultura do lugar
que você tem para as pessoas não
perderem motivação com trabalho delas
que acho que é diferente quando você tá
no UP não precisa se preocupar com isso
eu tô se preocupar com vender a sua
ideia né e ser eloquente e trazer Case
Mas eu sinto que no Bora um up você
consegue fazer cases para provar o seu
ponto né
E às vezes no
top não entanto que se diz é uma energia
up também
na sua carreira onde foi mais difícil
aparentemente menos de insides
eu tô trocando todos os tempos tranquilo
É depende memes
[Risadas]
é difícil mesmo
reclama lá no Glass Store
acho que
O mais difícil é quando você tomou top
Down e você precisa passar ele com
sutileza
é porque a vida tô de novo menos
difícil porque cara é um contexto que
provavelmente você tem pouca informação
do porque que aquilo tá né porque que
aquela Decisão foi tomada Então você vai
ter que ir atrás de informação atrás de
contexto para conseguir passar para o
time o porque tomaram aquela decisão de
uma forma
razoavelmente né racional que encaixa
ali com a estratégia que encaixa com
alguma dor que esteja querendo resolver
então
eu diria que mais difícil é isso assim
quando você toma vem alguma coisa que
você também não concorda Mas isso faz
parte do jogo né Qual é o qual é a
palavra para o José Green comente mesmo
que a gente usou eu já não lembro mas
era acho que era como trazer sutileza
mas como fazer isso certo porque se você
você vai levar top Down muitas vezes ele
é necessário tem tem top dar um que é
escrotice lá de cima tenta pegar um aqui
é maluquice
e os três têm maneiras diferentes de
você descer e principalmente o que você
discorda que você foi lá em cima e falou
olha deixa eu falar disso aqui lá em
cima Falou
com Deus né
falou eu sei que você tá falando isso
entendi mas não querendo ir para o outro
lado e você
decepção
mas não às vezes não pode mas o
julgamento
via de regra dessas três categorias a
maneira como você interpreta e cada uma
dessas três casinhas Vai mudar como você
vai dar o top dá um time depois isso e
acho que isso é difícil porque vamos
supor que você teve a percepção tá de
novo você teve essa percepção de que
alguém deu um top de escroto em você e
que não faz sentido e você falou a
pessoa falou não mesmo assim vamos você
como é que você desce sobre o time de um
jeito que não vai desanimar o time e
considerando que o time já sabe tá
alinhado contigo do caminho oposto que
foi mandado entendeu isso é muito
difícil Como fazer isso vamos falar
sobre terapia
cara
tem um ponto assim quando eu gosto de
pensar
que quando eu era PM eu tinha muito hate
nas pessoas que faziam isso E é isso que
tava um top Down E aí você vira a pessoa
que precisa dar o top então nas coisas
eu sou muito mais simpática quando eu tô
top do que eu era antigamente Então o
que eu tento fazer hoje em dia cara a
gente nunca é dono de toda a verdade
né então a pessoa Às vezes tem um
contexto maior do que o seu então vai
parecer que é escroto para você mas ela
tem um contexto maior e diferente do que
o que você tem naquele momento
então muito do que eu combino o jogo
assim cara vamos compartilhar com texto
contexto é rei mesmo que eu tenha um
pouco eu vou dar esse pouco de contexto
sem dizer que foi algo escroto né Mas eu
tento fazer muitas vezes é tá sei lá
vamos pintar essa lata aqui de roxo
beleza por que que a gente pintaria de
roxo aonde está por trás Qual que é a
lógica que lógica de pensamento poderia
estar aqui atrás e aí construir essa
lógica para conseguir descer para o time
E aí você vai ter que encontrar uma
lógica Porque para mim assim se você
acha que é errado desse tipo dizendo
assim olha pessoal eu não concordo muito
mas eles querem apostar nesse lado você
acha que você devia falar que você não
concorda e que você batalhou para não
conseguir ou não Você devia ser que você
tá comprada isso é relativa você não
precisa mostrar que você tá comprada
você pode mostrar o ponto de vista que
outra pessoa trouxe de uma forma
diferente então Ó o meu ponto de vista
era nessa linha mas trouxeram esse ponto
de vista e cara que que a gente faz em
produto a gente testa coisa então vamos
olhar na Perspectiva desse ponto de
vista como a gente valida se ele tá bom
ou não
eu acho que tem uma sutileza aí que é
delicada que é Eu por exemplo sou muito
transparente eu sempre falo tipo assim
mas eu acho que é você não pode meinar
confiança na liderança da empresa então
você não pode falar Tipo a putz top da
Auto discordo mas vão ter que fazer e é
isso você tem que falar tipo Poxa eu
discutir com tal pessoa Esse foi o
contexto Esse foi o racional eu sei que
a gente vê aquela outra discussão mas
assim cara eu confio muito na decisão
dessa pessoa Acho que essa pessoa
conhece muito do contexto daqui é
bastante tempo então vamos seguir a
recomendação dela e eu não consigo
negociar essa decisão agora então acho
que o importante é a forma que você
passa não pode ter toxicidade assim não
pode ter tipo recentemente com o que
aconteceu sabe você tem que trazer de
uma forma madura de uma forma tipo cara
normal tem hora que a gente vai
discordar mas a gente vai ter que seguir
o jogo
mas você não pode me dar a confiança
nessas lideranças maiores porque senão
você vai construindo essa Cultura de
tipo se eu falar não adianta para nada
né porque depois eu vou tomar top Down E
aí essa é a pior cultura que você
constrói numa empresa de produto né Na
real você perde o time né Legal enquanto
a Fernanda tiver aqui brigando por mim
legal mas e se ela sair talvez seja
melhor sair antes dela então sim e aí
daqui a pouco as pessoas estão querendo
ir embora você vira uma bolha né E na
verdade assim é muito louco assim agora
falando sobre terapia
e Psicologia por trás
quando alguém te dá um toque Down isso
te gera uma insegurança
e às vezes a gente tende a reagir mal
porque cara alguém pensou numa coisa que
eu não pensei logo eu sou incompetente
isso bem no subconsciente se eu sou
incompetente vou perder o meu emprego
caramba ferrou Então o que a gente
precisa pensar é assim por trás da nossa
reação até para colher a nossa reação
existe uma insegurança que é natural
quando você toma um top Down Então como
você também volta meio que dando
Highlight nas coisas que você é bom para
falar não tá tudo bem eu sou boa nisso
aqui e Cara outra pessoa só teve uma
ideia diferente na minha e beleza né
porque essa parte da insegurança ela
gera vários gatilhos de reação você acha
que isso vem mesmo quando você sabe que
a ideia da outra pessoa é ruim é pior
que a sua assim
isso que ia perguntar porque vocês estão
ainda assim
isso é uma bosta feio exato entendeu
um negócio que ela queria ter pensado
nisso pensei pô legal chego lá né mas
então a outra vai cair isso aqui é óbvio
que vai dar errado mas aí é evidente que
vai dar errado eu vou ter que dizer pro
meu time e o meu time não é trouxa é meu
time sabe que vai dar errado meu time
sabe até que eu jamais faria um negócio
desse exato não sei se já passar eu já
passei mas não vou contar essa história
de nada daqui a pouco eu conto pode ser
eu Socorro
essa essa caneca que é maravilhosa
godzil Berenice
um jeito de testar e argumentar Ah mas
feio mas desculpa pessoal só fazer um
follow rápido e se o seu teste deu
errado lá em cima a pessoa disse assim
não mas não testou direito
é normal isso é normal não porque eu
gosto o teste não foi bom o teste não
vai dizer aí você faz e mostra o
resultado E ele provavelmente vai ser
igual Resumindo engole o choro é isso
mas você faz mostra o resultado ele vai
ser igual ao teste ele vai ser igual o
teste aí você faz isso algumas vezes e
você vai só que depois você faz falou
viu olha que coisa foi igual o teste
bacana né porque você vai trazer
consciência para pessoa de que cara o
teste tem valor e a gente precisa testar
antes então tem vez você engole o choro
faz depois você volta falou que coisa
louca né deu exatamente a mesma coisa
incrível
eu acho que tem um ponto de escolher
suas brigas também nessa história que é
não foi tudo bem que tá mas já gravei
dois top dar os bem intensos um deles eu
falei cara Eu discordo mas assim eu não
vou ganhar essa briga eu não tenho que
fazer não adianta bater o pé sabe então
eu vou descer da melhor forma para o
time vou engolir engolir o choro e segue
o jogo e tem uma outra forma que é bater
o pé Então teve uma vez também que eu
bati o pé e eu falei não vou fazer não
vou falar isso para o time E aí num
ponto tipo assim não mas você tem que
fazer também não vou falar e a pessoa
fica me olhando como se eu fosse louca
não fui demitida então sim você usou o
velho bom na volta a gente compra não
comprou Exato eu falei eu só não vou
fazer e foi isso sim e eu bati o pé e
assim prejudicou minha relação com a
pessoa que me deu Total prejudicou Mas
eu achei que essa briga valia mais do
que fazer a merda entendeu Então eu
corri o risco eu falei eu entendo minha
posição na empresa
eu sei o valor que eu entrego sabe Então
nesse caso eu posso bater o pé é um bom
ponto porque tem um outro ponto que a Fê
falou ah você mostra você faz o teste
depois você chega com a pessoa e mostra
que os testes mas isso isso a gente fala
parece é coisa de um mês isso demora um
ano e ao mesmo tempo você pode ter tá
querendo mal hábito essa pessoa aí eu
quero também falar disso Porque conforme
você vai criando escala você começa a
ter muito mais pedidos e muito mais top
dá
porque você tem mais takeholders com
muita força porque às vezes não é o top
Down direto é que eles têm que Rodrigo
com muita força que ele chegou pelo cara
que pode te dar top Down e fala top Down
porque eu quero fazer assim então a
escala deixa uma complexidade maior e Se
você começar a dizer sim para os testes
o teste deu errado ah não mas você não
testou direito Faz de novo planeta um
negócio para outra ponta para aí sim
falar você cria um hábito de sempre que
ele falar deu errado você vai
implementar como é que você não cria
esse mal hábito somente a gente fala
porque você começa a ter pedidos e top
darwins vamos lá o tempo inteiro você
vai o que ela falou você vai ter que
comprar algumas brigas mas simplesmente
tem briga que vale a pena você comprar
mas que você tem argumento às vezes para
comprar tem briga que você pode
simplesmente falar vou fazer
e tá ali é igual tá ali no later no
backlog em algum momento vou botar aqui
para ir algum dia fazer que a gente pode
usar uma frase maravilhosa o saquinho de
ideia merda muito obrigada
é isso Adib lembranças saquinho de ideia
mesmo e
Então é isso assim tem hora cara você
vai ter que
ignorar vou fingir que não
tem uma clássica
gostei muito boa e se a gente não
fizesse
ótimo
que eu gosto muito que é muitas vezes as
pessoas estão assistindo tanto que eu
aguento e fala tá bom você quer fazer
vamos fazer tá aqui é top 5 próximas
coisas qual você tira do lugar
ela não tira nada primeiro que ela não
tem contente até cinco e segundo que ela
fala Putz melhor não meteu o dedo aqui
que se der ruim eu que vou levar pode
vir uma chance então vamos contratar
mais gente fazer seis coisas
contratado a gente faz Beleza vai
demorar seis meses até lá você já ganhou
espaço para fazer realmente a coisa
gente e pra gente sair de alinhamento
agora começar a entrar em algumas outras
discussões de desafio de escala por
exemplo como como funciona na discussão
aí Farina acho que é esse negócio de cor
roxa essa besteira aí e responde também
que é a empresa tem que focar no Core
investir eu digo no sentido de como ela
decide se ela tem que continuar focando
no Core ou se ela beleza agora está
escalando a gente tem mais pessoas e a
gente pode talvez buscar outras
oportunidades como é que ela normalmente
deve alocar esse percentual de pessoas
de produto também e obviamente de
engenharia em novas oportunidades ou
focando no Core ou então uma
oportunidades Ultra inovadoras né
começa comigo então contigo só para ti
olha
[Música]
dependendo
não de verdade eu acho que tem alguns
critérios para avaliar né primeiro o que
que acontece em todo momento de escala
de produto o que aconteceu provavelmente
aqui empresa achou um produto marketing
muito maneira ali começou a crescer
aquilo tá dando muito dinheiro contratou
muito mais gente para fazer várias
inovações incrementais e se ela não
prestar atenção ela vai ficar lá fazendo
inovação incremental até chegar alguém
que vai tirar ela daqui se é uma Startup
é mais engraçada ainda né porque ela foi
lá ela foi uma startuária ela lutou
contra empresas encomendentes tirou elas
de lá ela virou a encomendente Aí vem
uma Startup faz com ela que ela fez com
os outros e fica esse ciclo né que que o
dilema da Inovação ali que acho que é um
livro que aborda super bem isso
eu gosto mais de dilema da Inovação acho
que o Cleiton curry tem também Mas
independente disso eu acho que primeiro
também não dá para você aquele aquele
produto Estrela né ou vaca leiteira né
do desse jeito que tá ali dando dinheiro
que é o que paga a conta mas de certa
forma você tem que saber que todo
produto é feito para morrer aqui não vai
morrer em algum momento em algum momento
o critério que os clientes usam para
definir performance vai mudar né E o que
ele o que o cliente usava para definir
performance antes sei lá vou dar um
exemplo que não é da minha empresa
talvez vai pegar o Zé delivery pode ser
o tempo de entrega beleza para mim
performance é tempo de entrega quem
entregar mais rápido e ganhar e fica
todo mundo otimizando para tempo de
entrega daqui a pouco chega um que tenha
uma vasta é um vasto portfólio aqui de
cerveja artesanais que os outros não têm
eles entregam rápido mas eles não têm
cerveja artesanal e aí você perdeu esse
bonde então acho que você tem que estar
pelo menos fazendo algumas pesquisas
entendendo o que tá acontecendo com o
mercado tá em constante em contato mas
isso aí é a área de produto porque por
exemplo usar delivery é uma área muito
grande eu nem sei se é assim lá mas eu
acho uma empresa muito grande tem
quantas pessoas no lugar dele é pequeno
tem 700 pessoas a Ambev é grande beleza
mas 700 pessoas é pequeno é é um pequeno
para Ambev mas compara a questão é que
assim poucos mil para mim pequeno que é
50 pessoas 100 pessoas onde muita gente
ainda faz muita coisa que nem é sua
função diretamente mas por exemplo você
falou produto tem que estar acompanhando
o mercado não é uma área de estratégia
tamanho acho que é uma estratégia uma
área de pesquisa uma área de market
research sei lá o que que é mas que
produto vai estar super perto certo
porém é difícil dizer para não 30% para
inovação 70% por hora acho que não tem
essa essa receita de bolo mas acho que
você tem que estar ligado Quando que seu
produto morre o que que vai fazer seu
produto morrer
interessante se você faz você tá
conversando com seus usuários
continuamente Você sabe quando você tá
perdendo tração porque eles vão começar
a trazer outras coisas então a sua
proposta de valor inicial perdeu tração
Só que você tem que conversar e tá
próximo porque muitas vezes o que
acontece é tá aqui meu produto cresceu
massa vou deixar lá a vaca leiteira
rodando eu vou me dedicar a Inovação só
que vezes você se você olhar direito
para o que tá acontecendo Direto você
vai encontrar o que às vezes não é só
incremental o que às vezes são saltos
que você vai dar em cima do produto e aí
quando você pergunta quanto tempo você
coloca alok em cada coisa embora seja
complexo falar né eu gosto daquele uns
três três estágios lá da Inovação você
vai ter o produto Core você vai dedicar
um 20% ali do que é adjacente ao seu
produto cor Então você tem coisas que
são mais práticas ali do lado e tem
cinco porcento que tá muito além que um
dia você chega lá então tem a forma como
eu gosto de atribuir é mais ou menos
assim tipo tem o corte vai pegar um bom
pedaço do seu do seu tempo aqui são
adjacentes que são inovações mais
próximas do seu produto e outra coisa
que pode que é para matar o seu produto
no final das contas isso que você falou
de é para matar o seu produto você acha
que toda empresa devia ter um produto
que é para matar o seu produto ou só com
um latim de um estágio muito muito
grande porque eu já vi essa discussão ah
como a gente queria algo para matar a
gente como Netflix fez no Netflix atual
matou na Netflix antigo e a barracuster
e as locadoras enfim e agora tá quase E
agora mano
a questão é toda empresa devia ter isso
ou só quando atinge um certo nível de
tamanho porque vai escalando e a gente
vai tendo esses desafios ali Vamos
pensar não pela empresa mas pelo produto
maturidade do produto produto tem
estágio de maturidade então quando o seu
produto atinge o estágio de maturidade
que ele chegou no platô ali você precisa
começar a olhar enquanto você tá no
growthy grow growth vou crescer tá
tranquilo ali mas suave agora cara seu
produto começou a fazer o platô de andar
de lado
Aí você olha para isso ok talvez faça
sentido e sabe um negócio que acontece
nesse momento você já escalou para
caramba só de produto e você tem que
fazer isso com uma abeu separada né o
produto que vai matar a sua vaca
leiteira geralmente é o meu separado aí
os pênis todos estão no produto vaca
leiteira e fala assim que que eles estão
fazendo ali
Por que que eles estão inovando e a
gente tá aqui otimizando margem bruta
sabe e é isso aí é um baita desafio de
escala também seja gerenciar essa galera
que tá aqui falando pô eu queria estar
lá fazendo inovação
do dinheiro lá em várias ideias todas as
experimentação e tô aqui otimizando
margem pô coisa chata
desculpa
não eu ia falar nessa questão da de que
momento começa a mudar acho que eu falo
muito café e eu acho que tem uma coisa
meio cíclica assim né que é meio padrão
então Startup é sempre assim começa com
um produto foca muito em conseguir
Market Fit começa a ganhar a escala eu
acho que momento que você começa a olhar
é roubando que você falou comigo mais
cedo quando sua curva de crescimento
começa a cair um pouco né então você tem
aquele grupo acelerado quando
emagrecimento começa a cair Opa é hora
de olhar para o novo negócio e aí
obviamente vou continuar olhando o
negócio antigo e assim sempre você não
vai chutar 70% do negócio novo assim
sempre começo devagar no negócio novo e
aí acho que vai muito da estratégia de
portfólio da empresa também tem empresa
que vai ter um ou dois produtos e vai
ser isso o resto da vida e vai tentar
trabalhar muito forte naqueles produtos
e aí vai ter sempre times olhando para
possibilidade de tipo grandes pivotagens
né tipo Netflix por exemplo e vai ter
empresa que vai querer falar Putz faz
parte da minha estratégia tem vários
produtos no meu portfólio E aí para essa
empresa vai ser diferente de
distribuição Então acho que empresas que
tem poucos produtos você vai ter muita
coisa muito esforço no produto core e
algum esforço em inovação novas
oportunidades
que é bem similar ao Netflix até o
próprio nubank alguns sentidos enquanto
se você tem uma empresa que Putz não já
quero desde o começo jogar em diferentes
mercados já quero desde o começo ter um
portfólio de emprego de
jogos de produtos aí você tem que ter
isso muito mais consolidado então quando
eu trabalhava na Pepsi com jogos
eram portfólio de jogos o tempo todo que
a gente tinha que estar gerenciando
então era crucial para o business a
gente ter 70 80% do esforço em produtos
novos né fazer a parte no modelo de
negócio da empresa enquanto empresas de
um produto é o contrário ainda mais que
jogos é bem cíclico né muitas vezes você
não consegue manter a galera ali o jogo
é um produto que morre o jogo é um
produto que morre ele morre mais rápido
e ele morre bem mais rápido ele cresce
mais rápido
então depende muito essa estratégia mais
isso É bem interessante e essa história
também é de vocês podem falar assim
áries Tem que manter olhando para o
Cólera e continuar olhando ele e se você
for criar uma nova B1 ou negócio fazer
alguma coisa de inovação você tem ainda
que tentar Inovar no atual então é muito
difícil E aí entra numa complexidade que
eu quero que a gente agora desdobre que
é
como você contrata pessoas para estarem
ali em coisa que é TuneIn estarem também
coisas que a Inovação e ao mesmo tempo
você precisa você tá escalando Então
agora você precisa também ter leve ali
você precisa ter uma forma de avaliar se
as pessoas uma forma que elas consigam
saber como elas estão medidas e como
elas são Enfim
avaliadas no final das contas e aí
porque a empresa é pequenas sei lá 20 30
50 pessoas até 100 pessoas às vezes nem
leve ele tem Então você começa a ter
nessa necessidade depois de um período
Então como é que vocês acham que a gente
devia as pessoas que estão com o desafio
de escalar ou vão estar no desafio de
escalar e se preocupar com isso tanto de
alocação e perfil quanto de leve ali
para poder avaliar e montar um plano de
carreira também cara você vai ter perfis
Diferentes né tanto que você vê quando
Startup cresce a galera que começou na
Startup sai vai para outro Startup Aí
vem uma galera que tava em outra empresa
naquele estágio do mercado vem para cá
você tem esse movimento meio que natural
se olhar ao longo do tempo vídeo e aí
quando a empresa cresce vira uma empresa
de consolidada essa galera que tava aqui
na transição já não quer mais vai para
outra e aí vem a galera que tava no
outro mundo para cá então você tem os
perfis para cada momento né E quando
você precisa ter a dualidade dos perfis
né Então você vai ter um perfil olhando
para alguma coisa mais grande um outro
perfil que é um perfil statopeiro é um
perfil que gosta de cara tirar as
pedrinhas do caminho então você vai ter
dois perfis diferentes
as duas pessoas são de produto A
diferença é que o resultado e Impacto
que cada um causa é diferente então
enquanto em uma pessoa você vai olhar
que o resultado que ela tá causando tem
muito mais a ver Putz alinhamento de
stakeholders tá focada no resultado
impactou na métrica tal no outro você
vai cara qual foi a evolução das suas
descobertas o quanto rápido está
conseguindo evoluir testar no fundo são
duas coisas de produto se a gente olhar
numa matriz as duas coisas estão em
produto A diferença é que essa pessoa
vai ter Matriz apontando para um lado e
essa pessoa vai ter Matriz apontando
para o outro
também né que você consegue e de maneira
geral assim eu vejo que no mercado Tem
de se há pessoas mais séniors estarem um
pouco mais essa coisa de produtos novos
Eu sinto que porque é um cenário com
mais incerteza e mais ambiguidade né
quando está falando no cenário de
otimização de produto muitas vezes tá
falando de menos ambiguidade né tá
falando cara eu sei qual que é a médica
que eu tenho que mexer eu já tenho o meu
objetivo bem definido Às vezes o
problema bem definido Eu só preciso
trabalhar no espaço da solução enquanto
às vezes quando você for de produto novo
é tipo cara eu não sei nada eu tô
começando do zero aqui então
naturalmente você vai ter perfis também
às vezes um pouco mais séniors Então
pronto eu acho que é natural também
quando as pessoas vão se aneurisando
elas querem ir para Novos Produtos e
coisas que elas vão poder lidar com
essas ambiguidades maiores e tem gente
que não gosta tá tem gente que tá bem
ali no tem gente que gosta eu gosto por
exemplo de eu gosto disso mas eu gosto
dessa parte de tipo lidar com
complexidades da escala organizacional
sabe otimizar a locação de pessoas para
em função dos objetivos como é que você
tipo
reorganiza em cima de tipo 30 coisas
diferentes que você tem que fazer sabe
como é que você já era bom alinhamento
bons rituais é uma coisa que eu gosto
também então acho que varia muito também
do que tipo de PM você quer ser né você
você quer ser um PM de otimização sabe
mas você pode ter um PM unicórnio que
faz tudo isso que não é uma
certamente não sou eu também
é engraçado que vocês pulam né eu vejo
muito isso assim quem é perfil Market
Fit fica só nós você vai olhar o
Linkedin das pessoas passou por 20
empresa só vai falar essa pessoa
não aguenta ficar numa empresa mas não é
porque a empresa amadurece e fala não
tem mais que a gente aqui para mim quero
ir para outro para trabalhar e é muito
mais acelerado né que você tá numa
empresa bem pequena
super acelerado e realmente é algo que
tem que avaliar Qual o tamanho da
empresa e qual estágio que a pessoa
estava trabalhando ali para não ter esse
preconceito
indo indo para o dia a dia indo para nem
tanto dia a dia mas é algo até mais
estratégico
existe uma velha discussão do tipo
comprar ou construir e isso é uma
discussão que começa a acontecer cada
vez mais conforme você vai escalando a
área de produtos né como um todo mas
esse assunto sempre acaba tendo produto
no meio porque você tem que construir ou
se você vai comprar essa técnica
integral depois e como vocês acham que o
produto devia estar envolvido nisso
porque não é toda empresa que produto tá
envolvido muitas vezes produto é no
máximo consultado são raras as empresas
que envolvem produtos de maneira mais
próxima e às vezes vai compensar
realmente mais comprado e construir algo
do zero seja um ar seja uma cara não
porque aí não está construindo você vai
contratar para construir né no caso mas
e aí como vocês enxergam isso pelo que
você já vivenciaram
a minha visão depende da cultura da
empresa porque ter um mais de produto
não é uma coisa exclusivo de gerente de
produto né então o que é importante é
você tem um problema que você quer
resolver e você tem possíveis soluções
uma delas é comprar uma empresa ou
comprar um software outra delas é
construir a sua versão se a pessoa que
tá considerando isso tem esse mais tipo
a pessoa quer estudar por isso consegue
trazer essa perspectiva que é putz eu
tenho essas duas opções talvez eu
deveria envolver alguém de produto aqui
para ver os traid offs né Tipo se eu
fosse construir em casa Qualquer Custo
qualquer Impacto eu acho que é
importante envolver nesse momento assim
para você conseguir ter os três dólares
dessa decisão produto engenharia até né
os times de produto né acho que é
importante vou ver nesse momento assim
mas eu não diria que necessariamente
precisa ser um PM envolvido no processo
assim Acho que ele pode ser envolvido
mais nessa etapa se for uma empresa que
tem uma boa cultura de produtos assim eu
acho que depende muito da empresa você
tá numa empresa que não tem tanto essa
cultura aí é legal por todas do começo
para ajudar com isso assim pô Então a
gente tem esse problema para resolver
Quais são as possíveis soluções para
esse problema e aí Isso inclui várias
alternativas de compra várias
alternativas de jeito de construir
dentro e aí você monta sua Arvorezinha
de oportunidade ali para comparar
farinha tem uma visão aí sobre isso eu
Cara eu acho assim é super legal você
está capitalizado para adquirir empresa
mas a gente tem que tomar cuidado para
isso também não ser uma válvula de
escape para você não precisar Inovar
para você só sai comprando e não se
desenvolvendo E aí o seu grande Super
Poder do Batman ele tem dinheiro Então
ele nada aconteceu não foi picado por
uma aranha nada disso e trauma e trauma
é isso então se você é uma empresa
Batman né que tem um trauma e muito
dinheiro você sai aí você não quer se
Inovar você sai comprando coisas sai
comprando tecnologia sai comprando tudo
isso aí né Eu nada contra eu acho que
tem empresas de sucesso assim mas não
são empresas que vão ter uma cultura de
produto e que talvez nem precisem
escalar uma área de produto porque aí
você chega lá dentro separado aí beleza
entendeu então Acho que sim eu acredito
que o produto deveria estar envolvido em
aquisições mas acho que principalmente
aquisições que são para acelerar
acho que essa não dá Para não envolver
produto porque se você já sabe que você
vai fazer aquilo de repente tem um
competidor seu ou sei lá uma empresa bem
menor mas que faz especificamente aquela
Fit eu já super redondinha prontinha
então não sei que lá você traz para
dentro de casa e aí Acho que até produto
Poderia ajudar a achar essas empresas e
levar para área de emendaí e falar pô
acho que a gente deveria comprar essa
galera né agora se é uma entrada em Nova
um novo mercado e uma coisa totalmente
nova eu não vejo produto se envolvendo
muito não Talvez um CPU um VP de produto
alguma coisa assim vou dar por exemplo
da único vai se quiser entrar num setor
totalmente novo que não seja o setor do
produto onde eu tô um setor que não é de
um produto nenhum dos produtos que a
gente tem eu não vejo Qual o Red de
produto seria envolvido Talvez o próprio
VP né mas acho que é uma decisão muito
mais
estratégico é muito mais negócio cara eu
vou ser polêmica na minha frase mas
cara a China chegou não chegou copiando
mas ela chegou onde chegou copiando
basicamente só para o mercado da própria
China ela tem muita dificuldade para
entrar nos mercados de quem Ela copiou
tudo bem mas Ela copiou coisas que já
existiam né
então assim uma das coisas que eu penso
é Tem coisa que só copia Alguém já fez e
aí você olha O Traidor Quanto tempo vou
demorar para copiar quanto tempo eu vou
demorar para contratar um serviço isso
tá integrado então que eu penso às vezes
cara não vamos inventar roda se alguém
já inventou vai gastar tempo com isso
para construir essa roda que essa roda
tem é tem várias rodas aqui para você
escolher escolhe só roda e põe a roda
aqui mas sabe o que eu acho que não foi
pronto pelo menos para mim você não foi
polêmica em nenhum momento porque isso
faz muito sentido e principalmente em
coisas pequenas Só que eu acho que
talvez se você quer montar uma nova
unidade de negócio como um todo eu acho
que só copiar não funciona tanto
e sim porque isso Impacto Acho que até
na cultura e vários aspectos teve o
exemplo da Rocket no Brasil que entrava
no Brasil copiando todos os modelos de
negócio tudo deu errado mentira teve
alguns exemplos mas muita coisa de
errado e era cópia cópia da Alemanha
copa de Israel copa não sei da onde
então acho copiar Business um pouco mais
difícil tem Business copiam os outros e
viram segundo lugar porque copiou
primeiro mas eu acho que copiar features
principalmente porque não concorrência
já fez já deu certo todo mundo feliz
Alguém já gastou o tempo testando aquilo
lá é encontre o Snapchat que não nos
deixa mentir né
agora o Facebook comprou o Instagram não
copiou porque era uma base de usuário
diferente era acho que era outra tese
não era uma tese de Road map sim eu
falei eu acho que quando é pra acelerar
a Hold Mac pode ter muito mérito porque
até você contratar as pessoas chegarem
você produzir aquilo da um ano dois anos
já tá pronto ali tá num valor muito mais
barato até do que dois anos de salário
de um time traz para nesse caso Apesar
né mas acho que tem coisa que que dá
para você fazer dentro de casa e copiar
mesmo tem também acho e entra num outro
ponto a gente falou alguns momentos de
alinhamento e aí eu quero entrar nesse
ponto só que no nível um pouco mais
baixo de alinhamento que é o que
priorização em escala justamente para
conflito de Word map conflito de
métricas conflito enfim de Squad vindo
para o lado dos opostos ou para o mesmo
caminho se for uma empresa muito grande
aí é louco hein pois é
esse problema aí
são líder de produto
Eu nunca eu quero saber como você
resolve esse problema Ou pelo menos me
digam os problemas que isso
geras será
entrevistou ele ou não usuário vai
gostar tem dois squats fazendo a mesma
Fiat ele vai ter duas fitchers ele vai
ter duas vezes na mesma fia então o
ideal é fazer igual fez ali no passado
ele criou dois times pra deixar
ele vai adorar ele quer tanto aquela
ficha tem dois squares fazendo isso
também
demite
não mas ó
você tem isso eu acho que é um problema
que sinceramente acho que ninguém
encontrou a fórmula talvez nem tenha né
mas que tem tentativas para você
Minimizar Tem coisas que você faz que
você minimiza esse efeito né então
tem alguns rituais de sim que você
consegue tirar alguma coisa tem outras
coisas de documentação que você vai
fazer a sincro no que ajuda mas no final
das contas boa parte do problema se
resolve com comunicação então quanto
mais você tornar essa comunicação fluida
mais fácil as pessoas olharem e fala
Olha a Camila tá fazendo a mesma coisa
que eu bacana e tem a parte do outro
lado que é desapegar se ela tá fazendo
Obrigada vou fazer outra coisa que
também às vezes você entra na disputa
tipo ela tá fazendo também mas como eu
sincronizo esse alinhamento porque eu
vou dar um exemplo já Participei de uma
empresa nem era tão grande assim
mais ou menos o tamanho do que causa
delivery hoje e a gente teve que fazer
um
pouco
três dias de pleno a empresa inteira
todo o time treina não toda Engenharia e
produto
Colono post-it na parede inteira assim
tudo e a gente fica bonito né
mas assim
apesar de três dias inteiro para isso
gente
só falar comunica e vê mas como fazer tá
cara eu gosto de pensar que a gente tem
se todos os times tiverem árvore de
oportunidades e a gente trocar sobre as
árvores de oportunidade boa parte desse
problema foi porque cara eu vou falar
para você qual hipótese que eu tô
trabalhando e que problema eu tô
tentando resolver e como eu tô tentando
resolver aí você que tá no outro Squad
vai olhar e falar Putz esse problema eu
também tenho como é que eu olho o que
que a pessoa tá fazendo então eu
Fernanda acho melhor caminho um
compartilhado de oportunidades em todo
mundo outro caminho que foi um caminho
que eu vi na última empresa que eu
trabalhei que funcionava razoavelmente
bem é utilizar a própria Manager para
organizar como programa as coisas e por
que programa porque cara pensa quando
você tá colocando sei lá falar o exemplo
do cartão de crédito pagamento online em
algum lugar o pagamento online não é só
um Squad que tem que resolver isso
normalmente vai ter mais três quatro
squads que estão ali trabalhando naquele
contexto Só que cada Squad vê o seu
direcionalmente E aí você precisa de uma
estrutura que Veja isso horizontalmente
então programa Manager é uma que pode te
ajudar se você colocar com esse contexto
para ajudar a ter a visão horizontal e
tirar dependências né mas se você não
compartilhou antes né Você tem dois
momentos e o Discovery
Eu acho que eu concordo café porque tem
tem escopos muito complexos né E que
você vai ter muitos squads e que você
precisa ter alguém que a pessoa Tipo na
prática você não tem tempo de alinhar
com todo mundo você precisa e ainda
assim liderar o seu time sabe então a
questão de ter um gestor de programa é
alguém que tenha tempo para fazer isso
só para fazer isso praticamente né então
quando bastante com a fé mas Eu discordo
de oportunidade eu acho que é verde
oportunidade é o tipo de coisa que é
muito legal na teoria mas na prática as
pessoas não vão ler porque é muita coisa
é muito complexo eu acho que a
ferramenta melhor para esse é o World
Map mesmo é tipo eu sei que Road Maps é
polêmico e o James Word map e etc
mas eu acho que você tem no Word map
mesmo que seja de problemas que você
quer resolver e tipo sugestões de
soluções assim sabe pô tem esse que é
aqui eu acho que eu vou fazer a b e c
não sei o time exato pode ser só um
Stepway que é uma forma visual de
mostrar isso mas fazer uma coisa
você consegue compartilhar E aí
normalmente a apresentação de
apresentação tipo
quadro Mestral que você rever seus que
os outros você conversa um pouco sobre
as iniciativas as oportunidades está
resolvendo aí você tem que ter um
materialzinho sumarizado que circule bem
pela empresa para as pessoas olharem
a árvore de oportunidades mas eram 10 PM
aí nesse tamanho funcionava porque eu
conseguia ver todas Então tinha ajuda e
aí tinha muitas vezes coisas que
apareciam em árvores de squares
diferentes e a gente já alinhava não
quem ia fazer porque era muito cedo não
era uma questão de Round map ainda era
só assim ó dentro dos problemas que você
quer resolver essas apostas aqui fazem
sentido lá também faz lá também faz Quem
chegar primeiro nessa dor pega assim que
era uma coisa que a gente tinha na RD
também na faixa de 15 PM mais ou menos
quando aí era rode-map não era árvore
mas assim também tinha várias apostas
que estavam em round Maps de squares
diferentes e o nosso acordo era Quem
chegar primeiro faz mas quando fizer
fala com os outros por favor porque a
gente garante que pelo menos você não
vai fazer um negócio que ninguém vai
reutilizar né É mas esse é o ponto assim
eu entendo que dependendo do tamanho
Talvez um programa menos de fato
bastante sentido Se for muito grande
mesmo porque o líder também tem tantas
atribuições Mas dependendo da situação
eu enxergo muito com papel do líder de
produto está nessa cerimônia de
alinhamento Leia esse documento e ver
por tem conflito não é o que eu quero
fazia mais claro numa escala ali de 10pm
talvez ainda dá para fazer com 10 a 15
primos ainda não era o líder eu mas a
gente meio que se conversava entre a
gente até orgânicas ali também uns 15 15
nessa parte é 15 quando eu saí mas acho
que 15 é o limite acho que eu acho que
até 10 assim é o confortável mas que
isso mais 15 acho que já eram quatro
tribos e era muito difícil uma aposta de
uma tribo tem a ver com a posse da outra
tribo era mais dentro da mesma tribo
tinha aí era mais comum e a gente acabou
pulando essa essa tampa eu queria voltar
que a gente falou bem rápido de leve ali
de perfil Manager porque porque eu
queria voltar um pouco nesse tema porque
já passei por algumas empresas e todas
as empresas tinham exatamente a mesma
maldita discussão do que por hora do que
não pôr no leva a gente tem 300 mil Live
300 mil mas
talvez a centena de levelings públicos
tanto no Brasil quanto fora do Brasil né
no Brasil não acho que não tem centenas
ainda
para o português se tornar esse conteúdo
acessível em português como é em
português nivelatria de carreira
nivelamento
só para você ver os níveis da área de
produtos das pessoas muito bom
faz sentido a gente ficar tendo mil
discussões da empresa para montar um
diferente adequado aquela empresa ou a
gente já sabe já temos já temos uma
maturidade suficiente na área de produto
para ter padrões e basicamente falar é
isso aqui que é esperado e a gente ter
menos trabalho e menos discussões E por
que eu tô fazendo essa pergunta porque
em todas que eu trabalhei o levelin o
nivelamento virou Um retalho porque
chegava alguém que faz esse trabalho
mostrava pra duas três pessoas ela
discordavam um bocado conversavam a
fazer um Retalho para mais outra
discordava mais retalhar e depois
retalha seis meses de várias retalhadas
e o nivelamento ficava uma bagunça então
o que que vocês acha porque toda vez que
eu vejo olha os produtos escalando mesma
coisa em todas as empresas Posso fazer
uma pergunta adicional assim Manda
quando você chega numa empresa como
líder de produto você olha ali os
descritivos de cada nível de PM para
saber é isso que eu vou exigir dos meus
fêmeas ou você exige O que você acha que
é certo
deixo para vocês essa pergunta
[Risadas]
é quase uma pergunta retórica eu acho
que de novo vai para a pergunta vai para
a escala da empresa eu acho que com
poucos PMs Provavelmente você tem um
pouco mais de uniformidade no papel você
consegue ter tipo assim ah cada pema
cuida de um Squad e tá beleza quando
você tá numa empresa grande exemplo
nubank você vai ter pênis no Squad super
técnicos que às vezes vai ter cliente
interno vai ter um monte de coisa
regulatória para lidar tem um perfil
diferente que às vezes até tem uma cara
mais projeto e você vai ter uma galera
que tá lá na inovação tipo só olhando
para sei lá a questão novos negócios
olhando para totalmente outro perfil
assim então quanto maior a sua empresa
mais diferença você vai ter dentro do
leveling E aí você vai ter essa colcha
de retalhos que você comentou um pouco
né tipo gente que tem o mesmo cara
fazendo coisas muito diferentes
Então eu acho que eu levo ele é
Principalmente um guia né ele não é um
escrito em pedra ele é cada vez um guia
para pessoa tá gerando valor no fundo
que você precisa de um gerente de
produto é aquele Maximize o valor dentro
do escopo ali que ele tá trabalhando né
então você precisa entender o valor ele
possa gerado de formas muito diferentes
pode ser tipo melhorando alinhamento
pode ser tipo melhorando dinâmica do
time no processo de delivery pode ser
puts revendas decisões de prioridade
mesmo e um papa mais estratégico Então o
que é mais justo é você vai ler a pessoa
em cima do valor que ela entregou então
você começa uma avaliação falando qual
que foi o valor que você entregou esse
semestre e perguntou as pessoas que que
essa pessoa gerou de valor semestre e aí
você faz uma avaliação em cima do valor
gerado E aí com isso você consegue ser
um pouco mais justo e o levain acaba
saindo só o seu guia mas eu concordo que
ele é tipo ele é vai ter falha não tem
como vai design vai ter falha porque
você não vai conseguir fazer um site só
eu lembro que no nubank antes de eu nem
sei se tá na versão atual
atual Eco da época que eu saí que na
época que eu saí tinha acabado de lançar
a versão nova tipo seis meses da versão
nova lá na época que a Mari tinha tinha
puxado e eu lembro que antes era um
levelin checklist a galera fala assim Ah
tem que fazer sem fazer isso próximo
performances meses vou fazer tudo isso
aí vou botar um chacris aí a versão a
época que eu peguei era um pouco mais
subjetiva justamente para adotar vários
cenários diferentes do que eu acho mais
um pouco mais interessante mas ainda
assim se você ler esse Live nubank ou
esse qualquer outro leve ele diz a mesma
coisa
só que com outras palavras que é um
pouco o ponto do Farina que é feito
muito curioso que você fez uma cara
sobre isso gente copia
para quem inventa a Roda para quem
inventou a roda copia e a grande verdade
é que assim conforme isso vai
meio que
sedimentando né porque tá ficando mais
rígido e tal né cara é tudo igual você
tem mais coisas
de produtos estruturas quando a gente
olha aqui vamos olhar a trilha de
carreira Tá tudo meio parecida em
qualquer empresa e as pessoas vão de uma
empresa para outra você vai de uma para
outra é um racional é o mesmo então
velho só copia e faz pega o modelo de
mercado se quiser montar uma da pm3
sugestão da pm3 de carreira pronto deixa
como sugestão a gente vai copiar porque
a gente faz no final das contas que a
gente está olhando
a gente vai olhar um monte de empresa
que tem isso público e vai copiar
Mas pensa que chegou na performance
de outra empresa é a Camila desenvolveu
um projeto ali dentro para desenhar o
leveling da própria empresa quem aqui
vai ser mais bem avaliado vou ver várias
stakeholders desenhou um nivelamento
específico para nossa empresa que é
igualzinho que a Fernanda propôs mas ela
fez o projeto que que tá ligado
nome está junto com os valores tem o
valor que essas é senso de dono tem lá
senso de dono entendeu
esteja lá no nível dela que ela tem que
puxar projetos estratégicos e aí puxar
projeto estratégico não é copiar o
nivelamento Fernanda é que desenvolver
um novo que ainda vai entregar o mais
valor do que você tá fazendo mas essa é
essa essa é a ironia da coisa porque
assim no fim das contas eu acho que
muitas vezes as pessoas falam assim
vamos puxar o nosso próprio nivelamento
vai ficar igual mas mas ela vai brilhar
né porque ela vai conseguir também amar
desse lado da mesa
é só pode tremedeira tipo
é que vocês estão políticas diferentes
não mas ó não discordei de você eu
concordei com você eu disse que sim para
mim tem que copiar e tem vários exemplos
gente na boa né você vai fazer uma
caneca você não vai Inovar na caneca
igual é uma caneca
você vai tocar a cara da caneca e
colocar com os valores da empresa é
tocar a embalagem
também até hoje em dia o valor de ação a
mesma coisa pega o valor escolhe sem
empresas olha elas é a mesma coisa com
outro nome é a mesma coisa
nos valores lá do pessoal do 3G da AMBEV
que são bem parecidos que tem tem um
livro não lembro qual é o livro mas tem
um livro que fala os valores que o
pessoal lá lema não lembra os outros
fundadores fizeram e eu vejo muitas
empresas meio que copiando isso são 10
valores Ah não sei de cabeça não ainda
não
é gente
onde você vai botar seu esforço velho
aqui eu adorei eu super concordo
feedback tá meio amargo mesmo
é importante a gente falar as coisas que
as pessoas não estão falando é verdade
trazer o elefante tá na sala fala ó tem
um elefante na sala aqui galera é só
Missão de Vida
Não sei não
mas eu tendo a concordar inclusive todas
as vezes que eu passei de fato pelo
processo de leve que que a gente fazia a
gente procurava é que na época
e na época era fora do Brasil porque não
tinha tanto mas hoje em dia até no
Brasil tem tanto mais se faz o quê
marcar com a galera não sei o quê pede
para eu falar uma de fulano fala com
alguém do fundo para falar com alguém lá
do fundo da empresa x lá fora no vale é
a mesma coisa cara não sei se você já
viu tem uma tirinha você vê lá que ele
fala existem 10 padrões de mercado
precisamos unificar Vamos criar um único
pra unificar aí na outra tirinha existem
[Música]
só tem um ponto que Eu discordo que é Eu
ainda acho que produto faz uma coisa
diferente em cada empresa assim tipo tem
muita empresa que é levemente diferente
tem muita diferença do que é pior para
que é pm tem empresa que unifica tem
empresa que unifica então
eu acho que tem variações assim que são
um pouco mais estruturais eu acho eu
acho que bom a gente vai entrar num
ponto um pouco complexo agora porque
assim eu acho que o PM mesmo a gente vai
falando pelo próprio Manager existe um
padrão a questão é que algumas empresas
de fato vão lá e chamam esse que chama
uma pessoa de prata menos uma lista de
produto ou ela amplo ou alguma coisa ela
é um Na minha opinião é um carro um
pouco abaixo e executando outras coisas
executando algo um pouco mais
operacional do que um PM Originalmente
deveria estar executando acho que o
problema é mais de definição de cargo
pode ser entendimento da empresa do que
o nivelamento e mesmo que fosse o
nivelamento problema e de fato mesmo
vamos supor que todo mundo esteja
atuando o compro né de maneira correta
existe sim ali seus 20 30% de contexto
da empresa às vezes é uma empresa que
trabalha com hardware então ciclo é mais
longo às vezes uma empresa que trabalha
com algo regulatório como fintex o ciclo
é diferente Ou é uma empresa que é um
Marketplace com mundo físico sei lá por
exemplo aquele produto lá turb que você
pega um carro e tal complexidade
diferente então esses 20 30% devia ser
um se a gente tivesse um Live limpa
padrão devia ser um preencha aqui no seu
a sua cultura e aí o seu modelo de
negócio e a diferença porque o hashtag
cara do maneiro para criar é olha isso
aqui é o quê Você quer o quê o cara que
manja de delivery o cara que manja de
discovery A pessoa que tem é a pessoa
que sabe vedados
e quinta do mercado que você tá atuando
é isso é isso não tem mais o quê
aí você vai o Júnior é isso o nível
pleno é isso O senhor é isso é a mesma
coisa o que muda ela entende hardware
não Ela sabe ela entende do modelo
celular de negócio xpto ou não mas é a
parte que muda sim então é por isso que
eu acho que a gente devia se preocupar
menos em benchmarks etc
e principalmente a empresa hoje esteja
cara tudo que você puder copiar para
você ganhar velocidade outras coisas
copia cara tipo foca não quer ser
diferencial não quer o mesmo dos outros
assim eu queria jogar mais uma pergunta
para vocês que é sobre feedbacks e que
que eu quero dizer com isso porque hoje
eu quero chegar com isso porque como a
gente vai crescendo as pessoas de
produto tende a interagir com muitas
outras áreas
muito mais gente e aí você como líder
dessa dessa ou dessas pessoas de
produtos você tem que pedir feedback
para quantidade relativamente grande de
pessoas e o contrário acontece com o
líder também e é mais nesse ponto que eu
quero focar o líder começa a receber
solicitações de feedbacks de diversas
áreas diversas pessoas aí você tem ali
no CPF uma serview você tem que dar
feedback para 15 para 20 pessoas é tipo
assim são semanas de trabalho para você
dar um bom feedback para tudo isso de
pessoas vocês acham que isso é um
formato ideal na hora que você escala
uma empresa e ni áreas ou a gente
deveria pensar em uma forma diferente
disso para não deixar as pessoas
sobrecarregadas porque o tempo fica
sobrecarregado e o líder também
[Risadas]
super importante e tal mas assim sem
esses ciclo de performance são sempre
muito pesados tipo é um pesadelo para
gestão é um pesadelo para qualquer PM no
geral
e é meio inevitável assim tipo você
acaba não é muito difícil ter uma visão
completa do trabalho da pessoa sem você
falar com x pessoas ali que ela que são
chave que para você conseguir ter uma
visão mais concreta do que que tá
acontecendo assim a forma da gente não
ficar louco com isso que eu vejo é você
limitar o número de liderados que você
tem tipo assim essa coisa de ter 15 PMs
10 PM num Líder cara não dá você fica
louco só vai passar dois meses fazendo
ciclo de performance
você tem que limitar um pouco tão bom
equilíbrio assim principalmente se você
tiver pênis muitos Júniors ter pessoa
ter tipo menos não vai ter um gerente
produto ali com 10 Júnior sabe não dá
você precisa ter mais tempo de ficar
pessoas Então acho que isso é um jeito
de equilibrar Sabe tem um já falei isso
10 vezes né tem o Rachel melhor
e a outra forma de dar uma mitigada aí
você tem que estar meio que limitar sem
falar cara eu vou falar com o tipo três
pessoas por liderado você meio que fazer
umas formulhinhas assim para você
conseguir ter
o número mais
controlável você tem que ter E aí tem as
ferramentas de feedback assim que você
pode usar tipo tudo bem que usa o Cut
the rock mas tem n ferramentas para
fazer isso o problema dessas ferramentas
que eu vejo é que as pessoas não são
100% sinceras porque a pessoa que tá
recebendo feedback vai ver aquilo então
muitas vezes você tem que falar com a
pessoa então uma coisa que
eu por exemplo aprendi a pedir os meus
liderados é eu não quero que você receba
feedback aberto nessas ferramentas eu
quero que você peça o feedback em
específico em relação a esses pontos que
são tipos que eu quero entender melhor
como é que você tá aí e aí isso ajuda
bastante muitas vezes nas ferramentas já
vai vir uma coisa bem mais direcionada
bem mais específica
Isso é muito bom mesmo
foi a forma que eu fiquei menos louca
mas assim
eu sempre odeio esse momento assim tipo
é muito cansativo
que funciona né mas o que eu prefiro né
e o que eu adoto como liderança é cara
feedback contínuo não esperar o momento
do performance review performance
de tudo que a gente falou e para você tá
conectado com as outras pessoas você
também tem que estar aberto a ouvir de
forma contínua ter essa troca contínua
com todo mundo então Putz alguém vai
falar sobre você eu vou entender Beleza
deixa eu falar logo com você sobre isso
para a gente resolver um feedback que a
pessoa te deu sabe vamos fazer isso mais
leve porque tem que parar para fazer
nosso grande momento eu entendo por uma
questão de Budget tá E que aí preciso
organizar porque você precisa ter os
momentos desses grandes saltos mas
pensando numa lógica natural para as
pessoas não faz sentido
ter um momento de performance civil
porque você cria um pico de ansiedade
que tá todo mundo esperando performance
review e todo mundo espera que depois do
performance review receba alguma coisa
então podiam receber um aumento você
pode ver os Picos de turnover de todas
as empresas é pós performance ou pós
bônus
agora se o bônus tiver atrelado a sua
nota da performance
ele é muito sincronizado isso então a
gente tem que tentar seriamente Eu nunca
parei para explorar inclusive sair de RH
muitos anos por isso porque não concordo
mas enfim eu acho que se a gente
explorasse soluções diferentes a gente
encontraria sem essa forma de fazer sem
ter que parar a empresa inteira um mês
todo mundo fazendo performance review
dando ansiedade em todo mundo e todo
mundo depois espera no momento alguma
coisa que depois que todo mundo da
feedback sobre todo mundo ainda vai lá e
calibra né então Eu acho que o que as
pessoas falaram do Marcelo não é
exatamente o que o Marcelo eu vou baixar
nota calibração vou baixar nota dele
porque eu acho que as pessoas estão
erradas sobre Marcelo então aí ainda vai
vem curva forçada você vai usar ou não a
maioria tem gente que usa e diz que não
usa também Enfim então vem todo esse
processo aqui depois que as pessoas já
deram e receberam feedback elas ainda
espera às vezes um mês um mês e meio
para receber a devolutiva porque tem
todo toda calibragem e é caríssimo o
salário de um monte de executivo gestora
etc fazendo aquela calibrando a galera
para ainda chegar no final das vezes
você correr o risco de perder vários
também é E sem contar que assim é tipo
nem tocar nesse ponto mas muitas vezes
vamos supor você é um PM que teve
interação com pessoas em áreas os
líderes pedem para você avaliar aí você
tem 20 feedbacks para dar um dois times
para tocar de escolha pra 20 feedbacks
cara então assim um outro problema que
eu vejo deveria limitar a quantidade de
feedback porque cada pessoa mas isso
acho que algumas empresas já estão
fazendo é eu acho que já tá mais comum
você limitar a quantidade Você viu que
eu tinha 15 eu já fiz também e na
verdade eu já fiz com 20 mais limitaram
depois no semestre o seguinte limitaram
mas logo depois fala cara isso é surreal
não dá para fazer e até mesmo para
calibrar você começou a ser a calibragem
só por cada área não é não tinha mais
aquela calibrar todo mundo juntava todos
os líderes era por área e depois os VPS
podiam só subir mais 02 em cada área ou
desse 0.3 todo mundo da área faz mais
sentido mas ainda assim são mais brother
tem área aqui pega mais pesada e ainda
assim tem muito custo nisso que talvez
que às vezes não compensa mas como é que
como é que você mede desempenho das
pessoas
não é necessário tipo assim não tem
outra coisa para colocar no lugar hoje
não
não se inovou ainda o ponto de chegar a
uma solução fica aí a dica e acho que o
que tá saindo feito é inovações
incrementais né reduz a quantidade de
pessoas Sei lá deixar calibragem mais
enxuta e tal mas no fim das contas
ninguém pensou o modelo né E tem uma
coisa interessante sobre o performance
que eu comecei a me questionar nos
últimos anos assim cara o sistema foi
feito para as pessoas que estão no
sistema e se favorecem dele então o
sistema quando eu crio o sistema de
avaliação ele foi criado por pessoas
brancas com privilégios que estão ali
avaliando porque criou-se para avaliar
aquelas pessoas que estavam lá quando
você quer inserir diversidade no
ambiente você vai ter pessoas diferentes
daquelas que criaram o sistema você
deveria mudar o sistema só que hoje a
gente vive meio que um Frankstein Eu
tenho um sistema que foi criado por um
tipo de grupo de pessoa E aí você tá com
toda adversidade querendo entrar nas
empresas só que o sistema não permite
avaliar Então por mais que a gente fale
sobre quebra de viés uma série de coisas
a gente precisa rever o sistema se não
vai ficar um post durante dolorido
durante muito tempo para diversidade
Então essa é minha reflexão poé
nos últimos anos assim eu só acho que
tem que tomar um pouco de cuidado com
essa coisa do Adversidade muda um pouco
a barra assim Acho que é não nem era
esse ponto não era esse
Como reconhecer o que cada um fez de bom
não espera que todo mundo Faça bom igual
os primeiros desafios como líder era era
lidar com liderados introvertidos porque
a pessoa que aparece menos ela não fala
muito nas reuniões e tudo mais é um
pouco diferente do meu perfil e aí você
ficar esperando assim ah não essa pessoa
quase nunca fala não sei o trabalho dela
não aparece aquele lá vai valer a mão e
que não é verdade então esse é o
primeiro foi eu lembro assim foi o
primeiro viés que eu tive que olhar e
falar cara eu não posso fazer isso
porque isso é muito engraçado porque o
primeiro erro acho que o líder iniciante
ia ser o primeiro erro é ah essa pessoa
não tá agindo como eu agiria Então ela
tá indo mal não é isso é gigante gigante
Mas pensa aqui cara quem criou né pra
avaliar disse que as pessoas têm que ser
super colaborativas
cara talvez tem uma pessoa que trabalha
super bem individualmente e que entrega
sim e que no time não entrega Quando
você bota ela num time maior ela não
consegue entregar tão bem não rende
também e tudo bem então como é que você
lidar com esse cenário diferente às
vezes está colocando ela de maneira
ineficiente
mas o sistema não permite se faça isso
porque isso aconteça eu acho que o
sistema tem uma questão também que é às
vezes pelo sistema pela planilha você
vai querer resolver as coisas que você
não faz tão bem no seu level só que às
vezes você não tá impulsionando a pessoa
pelo super poder dela né tipo só manda
muito bem execução tipo só que ela
precisa melhorar no Discover para poder
ser promovido assim sabe e às vezes não
às vezes meu a pessoa tá brilhando a
execução ela faz execução melhor que a
empresa inteira e às vezes está ali no
mesmo nível porque a gente tem nessa
cultura de leve tem uma coisa de
meio que criar uma
requisitos mínimos para você seguir sabe
e em vez de focar nas Forças das pessoas
Então eu acho que como mais flexível
esse leve com mais flexível é mais
focado no valor que você tá gerando etc
melhor e pensa assim que eu gosto de
pensar é que as pessoas têm histórias de
vidas diferentes provavelmente eu tenho
uma história de vida diferente do
farinado e da sua
na nossa é igual só não me citou na
frase
e não é um bom exemplo
as pessoas vão ter histórias de vidas
diferentes então muitas vezes por
exemplo a gente pode falar sobre
comunicação comunicação caso clássico de
as pessoas são agressivas na comunicação
Esse foi o feedback que eu tomei na
minha vida o tempo inteiro
eu tô bem calma
trabalhei muito isso para me adequar ao
sistema brincadeira
Não hoje é quinta-feira gente hoje é
quinta-feira
mas o que eu quero dizer assim muitas
vezes as pessoas falar essa pessoa tem
uma comunicação agressiva E aí bate
muito nesse ponto mas a gente não tenta
entender e não tenta ter empatia pelo
pela história de vida da pessoa para
desconstruir aquilo que ela passou para
você acolher E aí sim mudar
ou talvez tornar aquela comunicação
melhor se você direciona para algum
lugar então o que eu vejo quando eu falo
sobre né quebrar o sistema tem um pouco
a ver com isso assim tipo cara as
histórias de vidas são diferentes mas o
sistema quer que você tenha a mesma
história de vida todo mundo e aí você
vai avaliar a mesma coisa esse não é um
sistema que está pronto para diversidade
Nesse contexto de
ambiente diversos também é super
importante que tipo as pessoas aprendem
também ali da melhor com isso né às
vezes chega alguém então bem que a gente
passou muito porque tem muito
estrangeiro e americano tem estilo de
comunicação que é mega assertivo assim
sabe e para o brasileiro muitas vezes
ser agressivo porque tá sendo mega
assertivo e assim dá um feedback na lata
em público na frente de todo mundo e
tudo bem porque tipo é uma diferença
cultural mesmo assim não é que a pessoa
tem conta de vida que ela é agressiva
mesmo naquela tem uma violência nela
sabe então você também tem que preparar
as pessoas para não ficar porque às
vezes eu acho que tem um pouco de mi
assim às vezes eu acho que é tipo a
pessoa não tá E minha palavra péssima né
mas sim
mas
eu acho que às vezes tem um pouco de
tipo Poxa você não tá aberto para uma
pessoa diferente que tem um estilo
diferente dos seus você tá esperando uma
pessoa muito similar do jeito que você
pensa então tipo Às vezes tem até
feedback você tem que dar nem para a
pessoa é para as pessoas estão
trabalhando com ela assim ela falou Poxa
mas é isso que vocês conversaram com ela
vocês deram abertura vocês tentaram ver
por esse lado sabe que eu acho que essa
coisa de
como você escala também um pouco mais
diverso né
que encaixa com feedback em escala
sempre faz sentido e para a gente
encerrar farinha Você tem uma última
pergunta eu tenho eu queria voltar lá na
primeira pergunta já que a Camila falou
um pouco quando a gente tá falando
perguntou do maior desafio de escala de
produto só um pouco de escalar o risco a
versão a risco ou a tolerância risco eu
queria queria entender um pouco mais
isso assim na verdade porque
me surpreendeu não é uma resposta que eu
esperava assim é uma qual que é
exatamente o desafio disso na escala se
puder dar um pouco mais de contexto e a
gente falar um pouco sobre isso talvez
isso seja pensando um pouco mais
empresas tradicionais que estão mudando
para uma cultura de produto Mas tipo eu
sinto que muitas empresas querem ter
muita certezas né tipo assim eu vou
investir Tanto Em tal produto eu quero
ter tanto de retorno para ter um
Business que é Positivo né tipo assim
então você tem que ter muitas garantias
para você decidir investir em alguma
coisa e eu vejo que
muitas empresas que estão principalmente
em transformação digital nesse momento
momentos de inovação
você tem que mudar a cabeça das pessoas
de que tipo eu não tenho garantias para
te dar porque
por princípio o trabalho de produto não
tem garantias né mas eu vou te provar o
valor cedo né Eu vou provar o valor de
forma barata eu vou fazer MVP vou fazer
prova de conceito então é uma forma de
pensar totalmente diferente e que muitas
vezes autogestores eles não pensam dessa
forma até porque muita gente que tá no
topo da carreira Hoje começou a carreira
20 30 anos atrás
não existia produto não existia metade
do marketing que hoje a gente discute
Então o que eu vejo É principalmente
né para fazer gestão para cima eu vejo
que tem um pouco dessa coisa do risco de
você falar vamos lidar com o mesmo
garantias a gente vai vai ter que
assumir isso e ajudar as pessoas a falar
mais confortáveis com isso e entender
que faz do processo sim então acho que
era esse ponto que eu queria trazer não
sei se fez sentido eu ia te fazer uma
pergunta isso em cima disso assim você
acha que a mesma empresa ela nasce com
uma Startup geralmente Startup por
Excelência tem uma baita tolerância à
risco você acha que ao longo da escala a
mesma empresa pode ir perdendo essa
tolerância para agora que eu já tô
ganhando o jogo O ideal é que o mundo
não fosse tão vida louca e as coisas
fossem um pouco mais organizadinhos aqui
né você acha que a empresa mesmo vai
perdendo isso assim mas com certeza e eu
acho que é porque tipo você não pode
voltar atrás né tipo assim você teve um
investimento para você conseguir
estar crescendo mês a mês e de maneira
geral você não quer parar de crescer mês
a mês né tipo a sua curva da empresa tem
que ser mais um dispositivo para você
conseguir investimento para você
conseguir
equipes Running né então eu acho que
você tem que tomar mais riscos né etapa
de pau do marketing na etapa de você
fazer coisas realmente diferentes então
é normal que tem pode otimização na
etapa de grow você vai tomar menos
riscos e aí a forma de você voltar a
tomar risco é beleza Qual que é o
momento que eu olho para um produto novo
como muito que eu olho para uma inovação
E aí nesse você tem que isolar quem tá
trabalhando nesses contextos de produtos
novo de inovação um pouco desse firma de
risco falado não se preocupa com risco
se preocupa em provar um valor aqui para
mim então acho que tem um pouco de
crenças isoladas assim nem na empresa
também
e como é que é você tá numa empresa
gigantesca com o Zé delivery que segundo
você é pequenininho né você tem só 700
pessoas como que é essa essa diferença
assim né Eu imagino que Ambev deve ter
uma tolerância de risco diferente do Zé
ou não é a mesma cultura não tem como
ter a mesma tolerância porque é uma
empresa é uma se pedir uma indústria
verdade para uma indústria rodar você
tem que ter processo padrão otimização
que é diferente do mundo de produto onde
você tem que arriscar testar etc
então eles por natureza eles são opostos
mas
se você consegue entender que um é puxe
o outro é um eu tô empurrando e o outro
eu tenho que fazer nascer você consegue
conviver nesses dois mundos porque acho
que é o exercício né que tá sendo muito
bem feito
e aí o que acontece assim o que a Ambev
fez nos últimos anos foi criar empresas
menores fora da AMBEV que era ZX para
você ter inovação Então você criou
totalmente apartado por quê Porque o
corpo está focado em otimizar processo
para indústria do outro lado você tem a
Inovação E aí apaixonamento que a
Inovação começa a crescer você olha para
aquela indústria tudo e fala caramba tem
um monte de coisa boa aqui que agora que
eu tô começando a crescer eu vou
aproveitar do que Ambev já tem então
Putz não tenho que negociar preço de
cerveja quase ninguém
porque tá tudo ali então você já
aproveita tem uma otimização ali no seu
crescimento Então essa para mim é a
versão a risco ela existe e vai sempre
existir porque é o modelo mental da
indústria Então eu preciso de Minimizar
risco eu preciso otimizar custo mas ao
mesmo tempo existe uma
consciência de todo mundo de que vai ter
que tomar risco e aí escolher quais
essas quais riscos eles vão tomar então
funciona mais ou menos assim tipo se
você deixar todo mundo quer só otimizar
melhorar custo só que era o mundo já
ensinou que a gente precisa tomar risco
Então vamos tomar risco como dentro de
um cenário aqui que a gente consegue
conviver com esse risco
temos o Episódio de sob como escalar
como não né sobre os desafios de escalar
porque eu como é uma jornada quase única
a empresa tem que começar a dar certo aí
você tem que escalar área de produtos
aí depois você encontra sua jornada
porque enfim pelo que a gente viu hoje
cada empresa vai ter seus desafios né a
Ambev no grupo inteiro deve ter
susperidades e vocês tem que escalar de
diferente tudo bem que diferente de uma
único enfim cada uma tem seu desafio
então para você que assistiu até o final
agradeço e agradeço vocês terem
aguentado o nosso amargou e pessoal se
mexendo Espero que você deixe um like aí
nesse canal e nesse Episódio também
assim no nosso canal no YouTube para
ajudar as pessoas da nossa empresa
bateristas
por favor ajudem eles eles estão
cobrados
não na meta mas a gente quer que eles
Batam mesmo assim então assim nesse
canal só para saber assim
é uma meta um negócio Gourmet entendeu
entendeu
porque a gente dá cinco estrelas
é isso pronto importante
e se você tá ouvindo esse episódio em
algum lugar no Spotify etc deixa um
cinco estrelas falando no Spotify ou se
foi em outro lugar não vai ter nada para
você fazer mesmo então agradecer ter
ficado aqui até o final compartilha nas
redes sociais para as pessoas e tipo
assim
Tá bom então bom quero encerrar com isso
muito obrigado e inclusive deixa o
feedbacks também seja no canal no
YouTube seja enviando para alguém da pm3
Essa é a sua primeira temporada a gente
tá procurando forma de sempre tá
melhorando para trazer mais conteúdo
gratuito e obrigado pessoal obrigado
Fernanda Camila farinaz mais uma vez e
até a próxima pessoal